التقديم الفرنسي اعقبه بيان من اربع دول
اعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي حول قدرتها على
استيعاب المهاجرين غير الشرعيه ايطاليا
واليونان وقبرص ومالطا اكدت رفضها لفكره
ان دخول او دول الدخول الاولى هي نقاط
الهبوط الاوروبيه الوحيده الممكنه
للمهاجرين غير الشرعيه البيان الرباعي
اضاف ان عدد المهاجرين الذين استقبلتهم
دول اخرى اعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي لا
يمثل سوى قدر صغير للغايه من العدد الفعلي
للوافدين غير الشرعيين الدول الاربعه
ادانت عمليات السفن الخيريه الخاصه التي
تعمل باستقلاليه تامه عن سلطات الدوله
المختصه لانتشال مئات المهاجرين الذين يتم
انقاذهم في البحر فالحكومه الايطاليه
الجديده بقياده اقصى اليمين دخلت في
مواجهه منذ اسابيع مع منظمات انسانيه تنقذ
المهاجرين وسطى ووسط البحر المتوسط حيث
ترى روما ان الدول التي ترفع السفن علمها
يجب ان تاخذ المهاجرين وليس ايطاليا وهو
موقف تعارضه بشده الجماعات الانسانيه
والخبراء القانونيين ونشطاء حقوق الانسان
[موسيقى]